and amid the surging crime in major
cities across the country the left
continues to work towards
defunding the police a news story
on foxnews.com states that a soon to be
released report
will show that almost half of police
departments nationwide
are getting their budgets cut and in
other news about your security
the trump administration has just gotten
a big win
the supreme court has denied a request
to halt construction
of the border wall joining us now for
reaction dhs
acting deputies secretary ken cuccinelli
uh thank you so much for joining us
tonight i'd like you to first
react to the supreme court uh clearing
the way for some 2.5 billion dollars of
pentagon
allocated funds to be used for the
border wall
hey two enthusiastic thumbs up this is
uh
look the president has told us and he
has
directed his his administration to press
ahead aggressively but always within the
boundaries of the law
always within the boundaries of the law
and the supreme court acknowledged that
today
and has let the building of the wall
continue we passed 200 miles
more than a month ago will pass 300
miles before
well before the end of the summer and
will pass 400 miles
not long after that will certainly get
well over 400 miles by the end of the
year
just as this president promised so
supreme court has
has kept us free to do that customs
border protection and the army corps of
engineers are pressing ahead hard
to make it happen and today's win was a
big one
to make sure we stay on track for that
goal
it will and it will be most helpful
having been under the border as much as
i have
it will be a huge help to the the border
patrol no doubt about it
um i also want to get your reaction to
the story you can read about on
foxnews.com which is
this idea that half half of police
departments are getting budget cuts in
this time
and age right now i got to tell you
that's going to be devastating to the
country and it's residents where
they're supposed to be protecting the
citizenry you can't just go out and cut
their budget and not expect
you know to have a consequence
you know and that's why police become
police officers
is they want to do good and protect
their communities
of course you have the every so often
bad apple but there's no profession on
earth
that doesn't have that and and now um
for purely political reasons you have
left-wing governments city councils
mayors and so forth
cutting these budgets and and let's be
really clear about who is hurt the most
where do you need policing the most you
need it the most in the poorest
communities the communities that are
most crime ridden and they are
disproportionately minority
and this president is upset about that
he fights that
continuously as you know he's he passed
criminal justice reform
so it's a balance he's very tough very
tough on crime
but he also knows we need to get it
right he did what his predecessor
wouldn't do on the reform side and now
we have all these
left-wing local governments that are
trying to gut their police departments
you've seen in new york we're seeing it
all over the country
and it is bad news for the communities
that need it
the most it's amazing to me the
democrats love of government government
employees and more government
except when it comes to law enforcement
then they just want chaos and they're
okay with rioting and domestic terrorism
i mean that's the way i see it that's
what i see is going on
i i need you to comment give us the
latest about portland because there was
a transition based on what the governor
was doing with the state police
where is the line when the when
president trump might step in with the
national guard
is it getting better and will it solve
the problem
well it's it's the the violence was
declining this week and then last night
the state police did what we've been
asking them to do for months and that's
show up and um and they did show up
and they began doing the policing that
the portland police wouldn't do
around the courthouse and the federal
facilities and lo and behold
in two months we had our first night
without violence last night
uh all and this is an i told you so
moment really but we've still got to get
through the weekend weekends are always
tougher for the from a rioting and
violence standpoint we'll see how
tonight tomorrow night go
but we're going in the right direction
with part of the reason we were
positioned to go in the right direction
is because president trump supported us
in advancing officers into portland to
protect that courthouse to protect the
federal facilities
and frankly i think the state and local
governments were just embarrassed
that we were holding out the way we were
and doing our job and performing our
mission
where everywhere else in america even
other cities
where the president is at odd with the
ma at odds with the mayor
we still cooperate at the professional
law enforcement level
but not in portland and governor brown
has changed that
i will give her that credit this is a
win-win for uh for the president in this
administration and governor brown and
her state police
uh it makes portland look pathetic
more pathetic but uh be that as it may
they did what we asked took them a long
time to do it but as soon as they did it
it started to work
yeah it's amazing just have local law
enforcement do their job
it's amazing that that was a heavy lift
and ask thank you so much for joining
us this evening